[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 échos votre magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique du
territoire
tout de suite le sommaire de ce magazine
la réalité virtuelle une technologie
utilisée par bouygues construction
une stratégie d'innovation pour le
groupe spécialisé dans le bâtiment avec
différentes utilisations de cette
technologie nous sommes allez les
découvrir sur le site challenger à
guyancourt créer des graphiques élaborer
des scénarios en réalité virtuelle la
spécialité de la start-up cadre de chréa
installé au sein du cluster gennari ce
groupe à magny les hameaux
elle se développe de plus en plus grâce
au partenariat noué avec des grands
groupes
enfin retour sur l'actualité économique
en bref avec l'attribution du premier
prêt innovation par inès initiative sky
et la recherche de candidature pour
occuper la nouvelle boutique à l'essai
de magny les hameaux
direction le site challenger pour
commencer cette émission au siège social
de bouygues construction installée
historiquement à saint quentin en
yvelines
le groupe spécialisé dans le secteur du
bâtiment utilise la réalité virtuelle
dans sa stratégie
nous avons rencontré le directeur r&d du
groupe thiébaut clément et médias psia
spécialiste de la réalité virtuelle
c'est un géant mondial du secteur du
bâtiment le groupe bouygues construction
implantée ici sur le site challenger à
guyancourt 61 % de son activité effet à
l'international en 2018 l'entreprise a
réalisé un chiffre d'affaires de 12
milliards d'euros ce qui représente une
augmentation de 6% en un an et elle a
établi aussi un nouveau record avec 22,2
milliards d'euros de commandes inscrit
dans son carnet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons rejoint thiébaut clément
directeur recherche et développement
chez bouygues construction bonjour avec
vous nous allons notamment parlé de la
réalité virtuelle
comment vous l'utilisez vous chez
bouygues construction la réactivité elle
est un des axes stratégiques de notre
recherche et développement
alors parmi les réserves stratégiques
nous avons bien sûr le développement
durable l'amélioration de nos process et
puis lusage mieux comprendre les usages
c'est mieux comprendre les besoins de
nos clients et du coup s'adapter ce
qu'on va essayer de mettre en oeuvre
c'est de proposer un autre client de le
mettre en immersion dans une réalité qui
n'est pas encore construite
comment ça se met en place concrètement
sur ces trois piliers or sur le devant
du rab
on va penser bien sûr à biodiversité on
a parlé récemment dans la presse est
aussi économie circulaire sur les procès
soient plutôt orientée sur comment
améliorer notre processus de production
construire mieux et moins cher puisque
de qualité plus vite et moins cher et
sur le ciel usage c'est donc intégrer le
besoin d'un club de nos clients le
besoin nos clients
leur permettre éventuellement de faire
un choix de deux couleurs des matériaux
qui vont être mises en oeuvre mais aussi
leur proposer dans un masque et immersif
de les intégrer dans l'espace
environnant dans l'écosystème
environnement et de leur montrer la
localisation de leurs bâtiments futur
dispositif y demande dit beaucoup
d'investissements ça représente combien
d'investissement se l'intégration de la
réalité virtuelle chez bouygues
construction
l'investissement pour dl la recherche et
développement chez bouygues construction
représente à peu près 20 millions
d'investissements par an là était
virtuel city entre 1 millions un peu
moins d'un million depuis combien de
temps vous développez la réalité
virtuelle
ici donc l'héritier virtuel on a
commencé les premiers prémices en 2015
on a installé une salle réservée du cou
à cette technologie et progressivement
on a déployé dans l'ensemble des entités
en france mais aussi à l'étranger
on voit que du coup on peut développer
des formations à l'étranger on peut
aussi du cours au delà de la formation
intéresser des clients qui dans des
conditions de coût particulières peuvent
percevoir avoir une image et une image
finale de l'ouvragé qui n'est pas encore
construit ces mots clément merci
beaucoup directeur recherche et
développement chez bouygues construction
et je vous propose maintenant d'aller
tester un de ces dispositifs de réalité
virtuelle avec médias
[Musique]
nous sommes avec media ca doctorant à
l'université versailles saint quentin
bonjour bonjour vous effectuez
actuellement une recherche sur la
réalité virtuelle l'objet de votre thèse
du coup et en collaboration avec
bouygues construction alors est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer ce que j'ai dans
la main donc ce que vous avez c'est un
casque de réalité virtuelle donc c'est
le htc vaille c'est un des derniers
casques immersive sur le marché ce que
vous allez faire c'est que vous allez
porter d'accord donc vous pouvez je vous
équiper et l'idée c'est que vous allez
vous retrouver sur un chantier d'accord
virtuel donc il n'existe pas effective
avant que le maire garder un petit peu
au dessus de moi
vous avez une reproduction 3d d'un
chantier des lavoirs et sur le toit d'un
minimum si vous regardez derrière vous
vous allez voir voilà une série de ce
qu'on appelle les manches donc ces
fameuses ces fameux moulin on les
utilise pour former pour former des
menus des murs pardon vous avez en face
de vous une échelle qui clignote cette
île de casse vous permet soit de vous
déplacer vous avez vu que quand vous
marchez réellement vous avancez
également dans le dans le jeu willie
mays mais ça vous permet aussi si vous
regardez vous avez vous avez remarqué
que le chantier était très grand mais la
salle dans laquelle en est n'est pas
adapté la taille de la salle n'est pas
adapté au jeu donc ce qu'on peut faire
avec ce qu'est ce que l'asse se
téléporter donc pour cela que je vous ai
fourni une manette au début d'accord
donc là au niveau de votre pouce vous
avez un bouton voyez c'est le gros
disent oui si vous cliquez dessus pardon
vous allez voir apparaître ces convois
des flèches bleues oui cette canne à
pêche là si vous jouez sur la hauteur de
votre bras vous allez voir apparaître un
cercle orange
donc on va le viser le bas de l'échelle
si je relâche le bouton vous allez vous
retrouver là où se trouvait le cercle
actuellement et j'allais le perdre une
échelle juste devant moi demain voilà ça
vous permet de vous téléporter ça vous
permet de visiter de grands espaces
virtuels quand votre espace réel n'est
pas
n'est pas très grand vous êtes tétanisés
ça permet de préparer les collaborateurs
de bouygues construction à ce type de
conditions en fait là je veux vous
mettre dans une situation à risque dont
c'est une situation dans laquelle nos
collaborateurs peuvent se retrouver
l'idée c'est de savoir si ils ont ils
vont avoir le réflexe qui devrait avoir
en réalité donc si vous regardez un peu
à droite au bout de la passerelle vous
voyez à voir vous allez avoir un lot
orange qui clignent à tout le monde oui
on va faire c'est qu'on reste à les
porter jusqu'à ce halo donc là à ghlin
voyez vous avez pas toi y'a pas de
l'écurie télé à droite vous avez une
grue la grue qui commence à tourner et
qui arrivent vers vous voyez que l'idée
c'est en fait qu'est ce que vous faites
sachant que vous avez un objet une grue
qui arrive avec une chaîne aux goûts et
vous n'avez pas de sécurité on va se
reculer il fallait faire plus vite à mon
but quand je vous fais la démonstration
de fait c'est de vous pousser à la faute
pour voir ce que vous allez faire parce
que c'est le genre de choses que je peux
me permettre concrètement de vous mettre
dans des situations dangereuses de vous
faire chuter comme ici et de voir
finalement comment de dans un serious
game donc c'est le principe du serious
game c'est de vous apprendre quelque
chose de vous
de sortir avec une conclusion qui est là
c'est un jeu il m'arrive rien la
sensation n'était pas agréable du tout
en réalité ça peut être sa part avoir
des conséquences beaucoup plus graves
là vous voyez une table en face de vous
avec vos tubes je vous invite à vous
rapprocher de la tête donc on vous
téléportant très très bien là si vous
mettez la manette dans un des cubes peu
importe les blancs ou les rouges et ou
en cliquant sur la gâchette vous pourrez
le déplacer un exercice très très simple
mais qui ne va demander beaucoup de
dextérité cédant fait d'aligner les
cubes les uns sur les autres pour former
une tour d'accord on va commencer avec
les cubes blancs que je suis en train de
faire de mon traité c'est d'appuyer ça
commence à être flot en fait exactement
c'est d'utiliser clavier je suis ce que
je suis en train d'augmenter c'est celle
effet à
d'alcool dans le sang utilisé à ne pas
consommer d'alcool je suppose davantage
et à dire que sur une application qui
est un exercice pardon qui est très
simple comme juste aligné dès que vous
voyez il n'y a pas de tâche compliquée
finalement on n'y arrive pas alors sur
des tâches où l'on doit manipuler des
outils électriques détachement on doit
manipuler des objets lourds cela peut
avoir encore une fois des conséquences
beaucoup plus graves médias que ça merci
beaucoup pour se tester cette découverte
cette immersion finalement sur le
chantier pour justement sensibilisés à
la sécurité auprès des collaborateurs de
bouygues construction
merci à vous les images sont signés
aurélie rose et maintenant découverte
d'une start-up 50 chinoise elle s'est
lancée dans la réalité virtuelle grâce à
un projet développé avec bouygues
construction
aujourd'hui elle élabore des expériences
de réalité virtuelle plus approfondies
cette société c4 décret a intégré dans
le cluster generix group à magny les
hameaux reportage un collègue arrive
m'explique qu'il y à de la fumée dans le
couloir et que les autres collègues sont
déjà partis ceci est un exercice de
sécurité incendie version réalité
virtuelle un outil de formation pour
plonger l'utilisateur dans une
expérience proche du réel avec un feu
d'ordinateur tout autour de moi j'ai des
portes et au dessus d'une des portes je
vois de la fumée s'échapper j'ai
remarqué que j'avais des extincteurs à
la disposition je peut sonner l'alarmé
je peux enlever la goupille de
l'extincteur
et puis éteindre le feu comme dans la
réalité en appuyant sur la manette mais
j'ai une statistique qui me dit que j'ai
déclenché l'alarmé au bout de 30
secondes que l'électricité n'a pas été
coupée chose que j'aurais dû faire
j'ai éteint le feu en une minute 11
secondes je n'ai pas vidé l'extincteur
alors qu'il aurait fallu le faire mais
j'ai une prédiction de 100% à l'origine
des images et de la programmation de ce
scénario la start-up cap décret a une
expérience de réalité virtuelle avec
l'intégration d'objets réels qu'on
allait distinctes heures ici qui sont
équipés d'un 2
deux tracker qu'il permet d'être repérés
dans l'espace par le système de réalité
virtuelle qui sont ici et puis on en a
un second qui permet de savoir comment
et positionner la lance et puis on a
associé des interrupteurs pour savoir
quand la personne enlève la goupille
donkament l'extincteur et aussi quand
elle active la start-up 4 décret a été
lancé en 2009 spécialisée d'abord dans
la vidéo elle s'est tournée vers la
réalité virtuelle grâce à une commande
de bouygues construction en 2012 et en
travaillant à la présentation du siège
de bouygues construction
on a fait une application tactile une
visite 3d qui permettait de découvrir
l'ensemble des bâtiments et des
innovations mises en oeuvre au fil des
années les technologies ont évolué les
casques de réalité virtuelle se sont
transformés et les possibilités se sont
élargies création du concept et des
graphiques élaboration des scénarios
cadets créa collabore avec des grands
groupes du secteur de la mode de
l'automobile ou encore du numérique
ici c'est une expérience de réalité
virtuelle à plusieurs joueurs et en full
body
donc on a la possibilité de voir son
corps en entier bras corps jambes de
voir la partenaire avec qui on joue ou
le partenaire et puis l'ensemble du
décor est rendue tangibles et
aujourd'hui on arrive sur un métier qui
est très très dans le développement
informatique puisque ont créé des
interactions complexes
aujourd'hui qu'à décret a réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires de 500 mille euros
avec une croissance annuelle moyenne de
30%
on passe tout de suite à l'actualité
économique en bref dans les yvelines le
1er prix innovation d'initiative sky a
été attribué à la start up au d'avis
cette société incubés au ski cube est
spécialisé dans le secteur du maintien à
domicile des personnes âgées
ces missions diagnostiquer les besoins
des aidants pour les orienter vers les
prestataires de services créée en
octobre 2015 elles ciblent le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines ce près de
25000 euros va lui permettre de
faciliter son développement
c'est 25000 euros du coût rentrent en
compte courant d'associé
ce qui va me permettre de
potentiellement demander des subventions
plus importantes pour pour pour
valoriser aussi pour expérimenter pour
aller chercher des salariés pour prendre
des nouvelles prestations de service et
donc développer la société
elle propose un site collaboratif de de
genre nouveau c'est à dire c'est pas un
énième site de propositions de services
c'est un site de mise en relation
d'appréciation de cotation donc d'un
truc c'était une idée assez innovante
dans le domaine qui est le sien dead aux
solutions à la dépendance
magny les hameaux en collaboration avec
le parc naturel de chevreuse renouvelle
son opération ma boutique à laisser le
principe tester son projet de commerce
pendant un an dans un local à loyer
réduit au sein du quartier du buisson
objectif acquérir les compétences du
commerçant et tester la pérennité de son
projet pour candidater vous pouvez
contacter le parc naturel de chevreuse
une légère hausse du chômage au premier
trimestre 2010 9 dans les yvelines le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi sans
activité a augmenté de 0,1 pour cent sur
un an on constate une baisse de 0.4
point toutes catégories confondues le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi a augmenté
de 2 3% en un an dans le département
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]